[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen in meiner
torten welt was ihr geht's endlich mal
wieder eine nachgemachte reihe und zwar
haben sich bei meiner letzten
nachgemacht reihe ich weiß schon gar
nicht mehr was ich nach gemacht hat aber
es ist schon eine weile her und da haben
sie sich eigentlich ganz viele gewünscht
dass ich mal tricks nach macht und
deswegen gibt es jetzt heute trickst
nachgemacht von mir
und natürlich muss man erstmal wird nun
ein was ist überhaupt witz früher das
ist ja mal rider mittlerweile eines
tricks sollten bis zum heißen
ich wusste das selber auch nicht
wahrscheinlich noch zu jung aber das hat
mein mann mir erzählen und tricks das
sind ja einfach schokoriegel die in der
mitte einen keks haben
hier ist ein leckerer knuspriger keks
hier etwas karamell und dann wird das
ganze umhüllt mit schokolade und das
war's ja im prinzip schon
und ich habe zum beispiel einmal den
originalen tricks und einmal tricks mini
die gibt es ja in zwei verschiedenen
packungen und der unterschied liegt
eigentlich nur in der länge also die
sind beide gleich breit geistig dies ist
einfach nur unterschiedlich machen der
große ist neun zentimeter lang und dann
kleine 7,5 und ich werde ihn jetzt heute
nach machen und damit er auf original
beton nachgemacht wird
ich hab das jetzt alles schon auf
gemessen der keks ist 5 mm dick dann
kommt etwa so 23 mm vermenschlicht
obendrauf und daneben noch eine dicke
schotterschicht und bei dem keks es ist
jetzt wichtig dass man einen richtig
knusprigen keks team bekommt also das
soll zwar möbel seien aber eben auch
richtig richtig richtig knusprig kross
richtig krank und deswegen müssen wir
heute den keks packen und dann werden
wir ihn auf schneit und dann noch mal
packen damit er richtig gut
durchtrocknen und ich zeige euch jetzt
einfach mal die zutaten für den keks und
später dann bis karl wir brauchen 180
gramm butter vortag 120 gramm zucker 3
eigelb zwar auch auf 300 gramm mehl
feiern mag kann nur 60 g speisestärke
gleichzeitig berg eine prise salz und
eventuell drei esslöffel kalten
[Musik]
nachhelfen und die mutter ist jetzt auch
noch kalt
[Musik]
und jetzt lassen wir erst mal butter und
zucker verrühren
aber nicht auf höchster stufe sondern
nur auf niedriger stufe wir wollen
nämlich keine luft einschlagen sondern
wollen nur dass das nicht schön
verbindet können dann natürlich auch mit
den händen kneten
das macht jetzt einfach in der küche
[Musik]
hoffmann nachbarn und geschenken kann
man nicht gab es noch kurz raus und das
passt jetzt bei uns auch ganz perfekt
denn wir haben gestern schon
kokosmakronen gebacken und haben nur
eiweiß gebraucht und jetzt kann man das
ei gelten können das aufbrauchen und
kokosmakronen rezept das gibt es nächste
woche ein grad noch mal ganz klipp gehen
wir noch die trockenen zutaten also mail
und speisestärke dazu und lassen das
kurz zu einem schönen gärten mit teig
kneten
[Musik]
und wenn ihr merkt dass der teig ist
etwas zu trocken ist gebt ihr noch ein
bisschen wasser dazu also bis zu drei
esslöffeln sind okay messe es nicht sein
und dann solltet ihr einen schönen
garten teig haben der etwas fester ist
als normaler website
und da ich auch gar nicht gruselig weil
wir da mit drin haben und speisestärke
und es ist fast wie so eine art
knetmasse ist auch ein bisschen und den
knete ich jetzt einfach kurz zu einer
schönen kugel zusammen und können dann
auch gleich weiter benutzen
wenn jetzt nämlich einfach ein bisschen
mehr ich brauche gar nicht viel denn die
arbeiter auf dem silikon matte und
konnte so ein bisschen verstreichen
normalerweise braucht man gar keinen
mehr aber ich möchte das auch gleich
wieder anheben können und ich arbeitet
auf dieser seele vor mathe weil ich hier
auch eine zentimeter angabe hat und ich
werde jetzt die großen tricks machen und
diesen neun zentimeter lange und zwei
zentimeter breiten und deswegen rolle
ich mir dieses rechtecks schonung so in
der größe aus dass ich später einfach
wenig beim wenig verlust beim schneiden
haben ich wollte es jetzt 5 mm dick aus
und habe deswegen hier meine teig
abstandshalter dann wisst ihr ganz genau
dass der teig die richtige dicke hat
[Musik]
und ihr habt ihr jetzt gesehen ich habe
das rechteck so ausgerollt und dem ich
immer mal wieder bisher zusammengefaltet
habe und dann entsteht ebenso ein
rechteck und es ist jetzt bei mir etwas
größer als 27 zentimeter in der breite
sieht man jetzt hier und von der länge
her sind es etwa 40 cm und ich werde es
so auf einem backpapier legen und zwar
lege ich das backpapier einfach hier
drauf ich nehme mir auch keine back
folie weil ich später noch drauf
schneiden muss hier schneide ich jetzt
den überrest weg und jetzt kann ich das
gemeinsam mit dem back up hierum drehen
und ich werde das jetzt schon mal in
neun zentimeter aufteilen damit später
die längsstreifen dann eben schnell
zurecht schneiden kann
[Musik]
dieser abstand um neun zentimeter das
ist jetzt immer neuen gehen muss man
natürlich nicht so genau machen wenn man
jetzt einfach sagt ich möchte keine
originalgetreuen tricks kann man auch
einfach irgendeinen länge nehmen oder
auch die kleine version mehr das depot
zentimetern
man kann ja auch ein riesen verbrauch
machen aber das sei schwierig dem dann
zu schneiden und zu platzieren genau
damit meinen essen kann und hier
schneide ich mir jetzt auch schon mal
die 2 cm zurecht
und bevor ich das jetzt aber ganz
durchschneiden und dann dekoration und
schon habt wer dies vorher ein stechen
das geht entweder mit einer gabel oder
mit seinem roller gerät das ein
massagegerät ist an ihre hat neulich
versucht nicht umhin zu passieren dass
so ein gerät wo man einfach kein stechen
kann gleichmäßig zum beispiel brauchen
wir das auch bei den ecken oder man kann
es mit verschiedenen märkten nehmen weil
titel bei peter karras nehmen also des
tisches ziemlich vielseitig und mit dem
werde ich hier kurz die löcher vor ohren
und es hilft dann einfach dass der teig
später nicht aufgeht und keine blasen
wirft und einfach schön gleich bleibt
[Musik]
und dann sehe ich einfach auf mein blick
wir sind es jetzt fix dass ihr jetzt 18
stück in einer reihe ich habe drei
reihen also 83 sind 54 und eigentlich 61
aber samira hat ja ein bisschen keks
zeigt abbekommen
deswegen machen wir jetzt hier noch 54
und din a6 im ofen gebacken bei ober und
unterhitze bei 150 grad bitte nicht hört
sonja hell bleiben
da werde ich jetzt etwa 15 minuten
backen und dann setze ich sie ein
bisschen auseinander und wachse dann
einfach noch mal so dass sie ihn richtig
durch trocken
nach 15 minuten nehme ich das einfach
aus dem ofen das habe ich jetzt hier
schon und war mit einem messer noch mal
alle konturen nach womit sich einfach
jedes zweite stäbchen und selbst das
auto zweites backblech damit einfach ein
bisschen platz dazwischen bleibt nämlich
das gleich noch mal fertig backen kann
und dieser keks zeigt auch richtig
knusprig wird ihr fragt ihr euch
vielleicht wieso machst du das doch
kompliziert erst vor packen bei mir
danach schneiden beim wieder packen
alles ist so wie die diese teigmasse die
kann ich auf einmal komplett backen und
sie ist danach erst schneiden
habt ihr jetzt nach 15 minuten aber dann
verlassen vielleicht bricht und deswegen
habe ich schon vorher geschnitten
man könnte aber auch die einzelnen tag
stehe vor dem backen direkt
auseinandersetzen
aber da muss man extrem aufpassen dass
sie gerade liegen und
was rechtwinklig sinn und deswegen
rechnet dann einfach so also das ist
nicht viel mehr arbeit da hat man es
einfach schön sauber und richtig saubere
schöne teil standen wie man hier sieht
und dann werden sie noch mal einfach 15
bis 20 minuten fertig gebacken und dann
soll uns auch richtig schön knusprig die
cases sind jetzt gebacken und ich habe
sie hier auf dem haus kühl gitter
gegeben damit sie einfach ein bisschen
abkühlen können
und die sind auch richtig schön knusprig
hab schon probiert und werden gehen sie
noch abkühlen kann ich schon mal das
parlament vorbereiten
und wer zum beispiel wenn sneaker videos
sieht weiß dass ich doch schon mal
karamell gemacht habe man kann es jetzt
entweder mit fertigen karamellbonbons
machen wie dieser - oder wir helfen die
anderen und die anderen werden nass da
gab es ja noch andere bonbons teppich
auch schon benutzt die kammer jetzt
nehmen oder man macht seinen karamell
selber also wer sich bis den
arbeitsverträgen
schaut euch einfach das andere video an
mit dem sneakers rezept und macht
einfach dieses karamell noch mal nach
oder ihr könnt es so selber machen und
braucht nur noch vier zutaten 110 gramm
zucker sirup das setzen ganz
dickflüssiger glukosesirup gibt es zum
beispiel bei mir im shop ihr könnt aber
auch aus dem supermarkt einen nehmen zum
beispiel in karamellisieren
hier habe ich 180 gramm zucker 125 gramm
sahne und 65 gramm milch ich gebe jetzt
alle zutaten hier in internen tropf
und jetzt schaltete den herd auf die
höchste stufe und deshalb jetzt alles
gemeinsam aufkochen lassen dann muss es
einfach so lange köcheln bis wir die
richtige konsistenz haben karten dann
kochen wir das gefühl ich habe den top
übrigens ausgetauscht aber ein bisschen
zu klein weil das ganze küche ist
ziemlich stark
und da dürfte keine zu kleinen topf
nehmen und wir lassen das jetzt so lange
köcheln bis unser karamell die richtige
konsistenz einkochen
ich werde jetzt gleichen karamell oder
zucker thermometer dafür benutzen aber
es geht auch ohne
aber mit so einem zucker thermometer
habe ich einfach die optimale temperatur
ich kann da zum beispiel mein karamell
hart machen oder weich und es steht das
opfer mit rauf da steht dann hier zb
symbol oder softball und ich werde dann
das ganze auf wo etwa 120 grad erhitzen
dass es bei soft ist und dann habe ich
eben in weißes karamell und jetzt ist
die farbe ja so ein bisschen geld lich
aber gleich wird es dann karamell farben
also wir sind jetzt bei 110 grad sieht
man hier und jetzt ist das karamell noch
zu weit ich das
ich gebe es jetzt hier auf dem teller
ein wenig teils mit dem löffel oder
hermann trägt es kate noch nicht also
das ist nicht richtig
und deswegen erwarten bis es auf so wie
es hier steht bei softball bis auf etwa
125 ist
ich finde mal den farb- unterschied
sehen hier im vergleich zu dem anderen
aber das ist auch nicht ganz so wie ich
es haben möchte noch nicht klebrig sieht
man auch den unterschied sich das ganze
deutlich klebriger ich weiß nicht ob man
zieht aber man merkt es einfach vom
löffel herr so kann man es gar nicht
weiter verwenden das ist übrigens auch
das karamell was ich will nur wenig
kartoffelfelder mache habe ich nämlich
auch schon ausprobiert und werde ich
auch ganz bald macht motto wie lecker
und jetzt müsst ihr natürlich nach
möglichkeiten suchen wie man jetzt
diesen karamell auf die tricks regel
darauf bekommt da gibt es mehrere
varianten man kann zum beispiel die
tricks kekse damit über gießen dann etwa
war ziemlich fehlen arbeit und ziemlich
viel zauberei das runter tropfte und man
muss das wieder auffangen
dann wird schnell fest und es wird
einfach nicht schön man kann auch eine
form vorbereiten und da das karamell
rein gießen und die kekse oben drauf
legen
aber da habe ich die erfahrung gemacht
dass dann die kleinen täglich sehr
schnell brechen wenn man auseinander
schneidet da gibt es die variante dass
man dann einen großen tricks regel macht
da gibt es auch schon rezept im internet
für einen großen mega tricks regel aber
meiner meinung nach ist frank an tricks
regel mehr weil wer will schon so ein
riesen tricks essen mit seinem
durchmesser und so lange muss man dann
auch später zerschneiden und es klappt
einfach nicht so gut deswegen habe ich
jetzt hier eine möglichkeit dies war ein
bisschen aufwendig aber wirklich nicht
sehr
und wenn man sich dafür entscheidet so
was selber zu machen dann machen wir das
auch gerne und diese möglichkeit die
zeit
und zwar könnt ihr euch auch einfach so
eine kleine palette nehmen
wir haben den löffel oder mit butter
messe durchweg zeit könnt ihr das zum
beispiel mit den händen so ein bisschen
an drücken aber bitte bitte seid ganz
vorsichtig das karamell kann auch noch
sehr heiß sein
das parlament habe jetzt eine richtig
tolle temperatur
ich kann es jetzt mit der hand nehmen es
ist noch warm aber nicht heiß und da
kann ich jetzt richtig schön formen mit
der hand an drücken und dafür also wenig
mit der hand zu machen wollt müsst das
eben bisschen abkühlen lassen dass ihr
euch eben nicht mal verbrennt und dann
könnte die richtig schön die form eben
nach modellieren
[Musik]
so sehen dann die regel aus wenn sie
fertig überzogen sind die muss ich jetzt
erst mal kühl stellen damit ich die
gleichen schokolade übergeben kann
und falls ihr euch jetzt fragt wie
bekomme ich diesen topf jetzt wieder
sauber weil der kommentar ist jetzt
revidiert und auch ziemlich hart und
fest und klebrig gibt einfach etwas nach
vorn so etwa bisher also fast von selbst
es noch mal auf dem herd und jetzt auch
kochen und dann löst sich der zucker
eindringende wasser aufnehmen können das
nur noch bisschen abspülen mit
spülmittel
ich hoffe jetzt dass kovats ihre ich
nehme jetzt vollmilch kuvertüre obwohl
ich eigentlich mehr dass anbieter typ
bin aber auch die natur ich bin ja auch
mit vollmilch quartiere überzogen
rohstoffversorgung auch schon fix mit
weißer schokolade
das können auch weiße schokolade nehmen
oder ich würde jetzt zb sagt peter
nehmen und ich brauche etwa drei bis 400
gramm fett ihr schonmal schmelzen und
stellt das kühl und dann zeit gestellt
wie wir die tricks regel fertigstellen
ich hatte zwar eine korrekte bereits
temperiert ich habe das jetzt in meiner
ken wirth gemacht hat geht es nämlich
ganz schnell ganz einfach aber ich habe
auch schon ganz viele videos dazu
gemacht wie das eben auch ohne
temperiergeräte oder kenwood geht könnt
ihr in sneakers video oder auch in
meinem bounty video sehen dass verlinke
ich euch hier oben oder hier oder
interfax und ich habe jetzt hier auch
noch einen trick passier kein abkühlen
gitter habt jetzt werden wir die
sneakers riege überziehen
und wenn ihr kein abo liter habt könnt
ihr eine schüssel nehmen dazu
versteckspiele darüber geben und es hier
abtropfen lassen
ich nehme jetzt meine tricks briegel und
stellt die legte da ein freundlicher
rouladen rein und dann kann ich sie mit
der schokolade übergießen
dann habe ich ihn mit 2
aus bisher abtropfen lassen und legt
beim hören
hier könnten abdruck wir fangen die
schokolade wieder auf als die kuvertüre
und kann sie dann einfach wieder weiter
würden haben sobald sie etwas abgedruckt
sind wirklich sie hier
auf einem blatt papier und da können sie
dann vollständig erhalten
[Musik]
meine tricks möglich sind jetzt fest
geworden ich hatte sie kurz im
kühlschrank und jetzt werde ich die
oberfläche noch ein bisschen mit der
restlichen schokolade verschönern die
habe ich übrigens in so eine kleine tüte
gegeben in der gefährte und schneide ich
kotzen kleines loch war und jetzt möchte
ich hier einfach noch ein paar streifen
darüber machen
motiv
und wenn ihr das gemacht habt müsst ihr
sie einfach mal davor heben damit die
schokolade recht und links daran haften
bleibt
aber das muss nicht sein dass könnt ihr
machen wenn ihr wollt und ich gebe jetzt
einfach noch mal einen kühlschrank damit
sie komplett fest werden können und in
der zeit bereitet schon mein gott papier
vor ich werde jetzt gleich auch richtig
einfach so wie eben tricks in goldpapier
bundestag nicht und das rezept ist
eigentlich jetzt schon fertig ich habe
bisher glaube ich etwa zweieinhalb
stunden gebraucht ich habe aber auch
eine ganz große menge das heißt wenn er
nicht so viele machen wollt dann macht
einfach die hälfte wir haben 64
wir haben 64 stück das ist wirklich sehr
viel als ich würde euch empfehlen wir
jedes mal ausprobieren wollt einfach mal
die hälfte zu machen oder sogar nur ein
drittel also 20 stück da hat man schon
ganz viel zu tun
ich möchte jetzt diese gold verpackung
so ein bisschen nach basteln und habe
mir deswegen eine krawatte zurecht
geschnitten
cara platten kennt ihr ja und die habe
ich schon öfter benutzt die kann man
einfach zurechtschneiden und ich hab
hier noch in wachs papier eingepackt man
kann sie immer genau am anfang april
man kann auch einfach im karton oder ein
fach papier ganz viel überhaupt sah man
hat so eine unterlage und hier habe ich
jetzt so ein doppel alle papier in gold
man kann aber da zum beispiel auch
einfach goldenes geschenkpapier von der
breite her muss es jetzt etwa 2 cm
breiter sein auf jeder seite wie eben
eure unterlage als ihr könnt ihr machen
solange oder so kurz wie ihr wollt hier
unten
klicke ich jetzt ungefähr 5 mm
damit wir da so ein bisschen so ein
bisschen stabilität haben dann nehme ich
mir hier so doppelseitiges klebeband und
klebt darm einen karton drauf sind
mittig und jetzt von der breite her
müssen wir gucken wir wollen dass wir
hier so drüber schneiden
aber natürlich darf es nicht noch drauf
legen sonst passen die kleine schreit
sondern es muss ein bisschen mehr platz
beschließen
aber ich will jetzt dass die party hier
geöffnet ist damit ich sie aufklappen
kann jetzt gebe ich das hier erst mal
fest jetzt kann ich praktisch hier das
umklappen und könnt ihr unten immer
umgeben und so verschließen wird es dann
gebe ich da oben in die falte auch so
ein bisschen klebeband sollte nicht zu
viel sein weil wir das ja auch wieder
öffnen wollen
[Musik]
und jetzt sieht man hier
ich habe jetzt hier die öffnung und kann
da dann die tricks klein machen indem
ich das hier einfach öffnen an den
beiden stellen
man kann es dann da einlegen
[Musik]
und bevor wir jetzt hier die tricks
reinlegen will ich hier noch ein schönes
logo drauf machen
[Musik]
so sieht meiner verpackung jetzt auch
richtig kohle und ich habe dieses 52 und
diese tricks einfach hier von der
materie beschäftigt holen
[Musik]
so sieht jetzt unser vater verpackter
regel auf und es zieht richtig cool aus
mit der gerade eben supermarkt stehen
wenn neues elektrische ab sofort
erhältlich natürlich nur bei uns daheim
- und überall nur im fokus hier und
natürlich würde ich jetzt wenn ich das
ganze verschenken will ich hier rechts
und links noch verschließen aber
unsicher selbst nur als gag gedacht und
wünsche - foto und ich kann das hier
schon öffnen und kann hier meine regel
entnehmen und ich kann sind einmal
wieder verschließen und ihr fragt euch
jetzt wahrscheinlich wieso heißt der
regel fällig eigentlich ist doch ein
trick also wir haben gemerkt werden
sollen schon probiert und es war wenn
man diese rede ich mag ich die filme wie
das ist
und wenn man sie zerbricht er in der
mitte einfach dieser leckerer keks mit
karamell und schokolade
[Musik]
die zähne ein paar zähne putzen und
dieser regel schmeckt einfach mit tricks
und daheim in einem da karamell ist
nämlich richtig schön knackig und
eigentlich wollte ich anfangs oft um
haben hätte ich ein bisschen mehr sahne
dazugeben müssen aber so ist es einfach
richtig lecker und deswegen ist eine
neue regel und das ist das telex regel
und dieses rezept für den fsx regel gibt
es natürlich auch www.zeit.de da werde
ich euch aber auch rein schreiben falls
ihnen software barrieren gewohnt einfach
diese messe nehmen ich freue mich
natürlich über euer feedback ob ich
dieses video gefallen hat welche es
nachgemacht würdet ihr gerne als
nächstes 10 toffifee werde ich auf jeden
fall auch noch machen und wie lassen
sich diese leckeren riegel schmecken
gebt uns auf jeden fall eine bewertung
und wir freuen uns schon aufs nächste
mal wieder russland und auch diesen
riegel 6 und den regisseur überall ein
wahnsinn wie vor mir habe ich nochmal
kaufen
gültigkeit
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
die hose oder anders die von der frau
weihnachtsmann besagt steht in filme von
mir